en Times Square ultiman detalles para
despedir 2021 la tradicional espera que
marca el inicio de un nuevo año en la
gran manzana ya fue terminada
192 triángulos y más de 32000 bombillas
componen el artefacto de más de 5000 kg
que comenzara a descender cuando el
reloj marque las 11:59 de la noche del
31 de diciembre como lo ha hecho desde
su debut hace más de 100 años pero por
segundo año consecutivo el conteo
regresivo no contará con las más de
50000 voces que normalmente presencia en
el espectáculo en el corazón de
Manhattan el evento estará limitado solo
a 15000 asistentes para permitir mayor
distanciamiento social y todos ellos
deberán mostrar un comprobante de
vacunación y usar mascarillas de cara a
las festividades los neoyorquinos hacen
largas filas para hacerse la prueba y
descartar un contagio creo que para
momentos como estos deberías hacerte la
deberías hacerte la prueba
estamos cuidando de nuestra comunidad y
de nosotros mismos y es que a medida de
que los casos de covid-19 van en aumento
en el país debido a la variante Omicron
los gobiernos estatales empiezan a
imponer restricciones Nueva York comenzó
a exigir a sus 184.000 negocios que
demuestren que todos sus empleados han
sido vacunados todos los neoyorquinos
mayores de 18 años deben mostrar sus
certificados de vacunación para ingresar
a restaurantes y otros sitios de
entretenimiento y los menores de entre 5
y 11 años deberán tener al menos una
dosis para participar de actividades
extraescolares